if we want to build big businesses we
have to talk like big business owners
and know what that path looks like until
the beginning sure there's activity but
the goal should be to get out of those
activities as quickly as you can so that
you can go recruit the players on the
field you just have to run the ball long
enough to win a couple games at the
lowest levels of minor leagues enough
that people like this guy's pretty good
I think I could help him out and then
you recruit some better players and then
you run plays again and gets better
teams then eventually you do such a good
job that you can retire and then you
move up the ranks in that way